il peut lire que c'est dans cette ville
que les forces de l'ordre sur le qui
vive dans une rue parisienne
habituellement peuple et ses mesures de
couvre-feu existait déjà il débutait à
20 heures il a été avancé de deux heures
mais là aussi la population est
désormais l'habitude de ces mesures
donc la tolérance est bien moindre et si
des infractions sont constatées elles
seront relevés et verbaliser une
situation devenue presque normal se
confiner une nouvelle fois pour mieux
résister au virus
mais cette fois pas question de sortir
après sa journée de travail
personnellement je pense que la majorité
des gens vont faire leurs courses vont
faire les achats entre guillemets qui
leur sont essentiels à ces heures là le
problème c'est que ce couvre-feu en fait
qui passe de 20 heures à 18 heures va
énormément favoriser le télétravail est
pour moi qui qui adore me rendre sur mon
lieu de travail bien je serai on va dire
force et je pense que pour beaucoup de
gens ça va rentrer chez eux et puis
après la vie s'arrête
en rompant au boulot 21h20 heure 18
heures depuis trois mois le gouvernement
serre la vis en espérance juguler une
situation sanitaire compliqué la france
n'arrive pas à atteindre son objectif
passer sous la barre des 5000
contamination par jour depuis le début
de l'année 2021
il est question de vingt mille nouveaux
cas journaliers en moyenne des français
ces petits qu'aujourd'hui face au succès
du couvre feu
parce que si on va rentrer chez nous
avant 18 heures les gens ils vont ils
vont se concentrer dans le métro dans
les bus et ça va rien changer du tout
c'est vrai que les gens se rassemblent
un peu entre 18 et 20 heures en sortant
du travail du coup je pense que ce sera
un petit impact mais c'est vrai qu'on
voit le monde ici on sait pas trop où on
se pose des questions
et pourtant face au virus est assez
variée anglais sud africain le
couvre-feu semble avoir son efficacité
pour le premier ministre est selon la
communauté scientifique dans les 15
premiers départements où le couvre feu a
été mis en oeuvre à 18 heures le 2
janvier dernier la hausse du nombre de
nouveaux cas y ait deux voire trois fois
plus faible que dans les autres
départements métropolitains
très clairement les données des tests et
les données hospitalières sont en faveur
d'un impact de ces premiers couvre-feu
l'évolution des indicateurs a fortement
ralenti et les courbes ont ensuite chuté
un couvre-feu avancée qui questionne
d'autant plus que le gouvernement a
prévenu cette semaine
le pire serait encore à venir leur
confinement reste une option sur la
table si la situation devait se dégrader
fortement
nous verrons dans les jours les semaines
qui viennent si la circulation du virus
est contenue si cela ne suffit pas il y
aura un confinement
les français pourront toujours se
déplacer entre 18h et 6h du matin pour
motifs professionnels familiaux ou
encore judiciaire du monde muni d'une
attestation sous peine d'une amende
inchangé de 135 euros
à noter également que cinq communes de
guyane sont toujours concernés par le
couvre-feu
ce dernier passant de 21h
à 19 heures